It seems like a lot of people have a particular
experience while getting into the EDH format,
and that experience goes something like this:
they find a commander and deck that they really
gel with, like it speaks to them on some deep
level, and then they embark upon on a great
optimization quest, pouring increasing amounts of
time and money into making the deck as good as it
possibly can be. I went through this process about
ten years ago with my first commander deck, and I
understand this impulse—you’ve got your baby, and
you want it to fly. This process can work to some
extent, especially if you have big piles of money
to throw at upgrading a deck, and I encourage
everybody to put effort into making their decks
as enjoyable as possible for themselves, which
may mean power upgrades. That said, there are
actually some pretty compelling reasons *not* to
upgrade a deck further once it plays smoothly at
a healthy middling power level. So in this video,
I’m going to go through these reasons, using one
of my mid-power decks to exemplify each of them,
and then I’ll be talking about what decks
are the best candidates for an upgrade.
The first reason not to upgrade a deck is
that some decks have natural bottlenecks
in their functionality that makes it difficult
to give them a cohesive upgrade, and the most
common bottlenecks here are being vulnerable to
a particular type of hate or having a game plan
that is fundamentally difficult to speed up. If
your deck relies heavily on the board presence of
a commander that’s more than three mana, your
opponents only need to hate out your command
zone a couple times early in order to shut you
down. If your deck heavily relies on building up
a graveyard over the course of several turns, a
single piece of graveyard hate can totally blow
you out, and card quality improvements alone
won’t generally change this fact. If your deck
heavily uses board wipes to maintain control over
the game, or something like goad for that matter,
you’ll struggle against decks that don’t rely
on combat damage or which are more explosive,
which get more common at higher powers.
Ultimately, trying to improve a deck with
a bottleneck like this will generally lead to
some very good games with the deck, but much
worse consistency, with the deck getting dragged
down to the dirt by its bottlenecking factors a
decent portion of the time. This is the reason I
don’t upgrade my Sharuum Slide deck—there are ways
to make it much more efficient at generating
value and controlling the game, but the deck
has several vulnerabilities—its Astral Slides
getting hated out, its artifacts getting wiped,
and/or its graveyard getting exiled. The deck can
play through these things happening a little bit,
but decks generally run more of these things at
higher powers, and if it encounters too much of
these sorts of hate the deck will fall flat on
its face regardless of card quality upgrades.
An extension on this problem is what I’ll call
“the cheap deck”. This is a deck that works pretty
well at low budgets, but is very logarithmic in
terms of how it translates additional budget to
additional power—it gets rapidly more expensive
to improve past a certain power level. The best
example of this I can think of is Feather—it’s
a commander that has a decently beefy voltron
gameplan if you build your deck specifically
around it, which usually means running a lot
of 1-2 mana instants and sorceries that target
creatures along with some cards that work well
with these sorts of spells. It’s hard to end
up with a Feather deck that’s bad, but it’s
also hard to build a Feather deck that’s really
good—1 mana instants and sorceries that target
creatures are cheap so you’re already running
the best ones, meaning that the only option
for trying to improve the deck is cutting some
of these for generic value cards in the colors,
and the weakening of the Feather game plan that
this results in will negate some of that increase
in power. This reason is also why I don’t try to
improve my Meria deck: 1-2 mana equipments are
the deck’s bread and butter, and there just aren’t
that many options in this category of card outside
of the dirt cheap ones I’m already running
and ones I consider prohibitively expensive.
The other reason not to increase the power level
of a deck is if you simply don’t enjoy the power
level you end up at. If you’re playing in a group
of beatdown decks and everybody is relentlessly
tuning the effectiveness of their beatdown, that
might feel okay in that context, but your deck
might end up on the power level of a deck that
consistently combos off on turn 5 or voltron
kills you on turn 4 or forcefully suppresses
your deck into the dirt with an unending stream
of hate. And even if you’re still pulling off your
fair share of wins against these sorts of decks,
as a player you need to ask yourself the question
of if that’s the sort of MTG you want to be
playing. You also might need to slip combos
into your deck instead of winning in ways that
play more to the deck’s strengths, which a lot of
players might not find to be a satisfying way to
go with their deck. This reason is why I leave my
Glissa deck at a middling power level—it’s a deck
that wants to build up resources and then play
a bunch of big stuff, winning through gaining
board superiority and beating down its opponents
rather than playing some sort of explosive card
like Torment of Hailfire or tutoring up a combo.
I play the deck to do beefy battlecruiser things
and become the big bad of the table, not to pull
off a sneaky win when my opponents aren’t looking.
Okay, so the point I’m trying to make here is
that some decks are less ideal candidates for
upgrading past a certain point, you know,
you should maybe call them good enough. And
I do fully believe in this idea, but I think it’s
also useful to consider the terms here—what do we
mean by “upgrading” a deck? I’d say there are two
main factors that determine a deck’s power level:
card quality—how good the cards are,
and cohesion—how well the cards are put
together. I’d say that we as magic players tend
to overwhelmingly focus on the first one when we
think about a deck’s power level, particularly
when it comes to the question of upgrading,
and I actually think this makes perfect sense to
do. When you’re asking whether or not you should
improve your deck’s card quality, you’re talking
about an unambiguous exchange of resources—money
for power level—whereas cohesion is a much more
challenging factor to modulate, particularly for
a deck that’s already fully-built. With that in
mind, I’d like to offer an additional framework:
you can think of upgrading your deck’s
card quality as a tool for obtaining the
deck’s desired power level. If you have a
fundamentally janky premise for a deck that
you want to end up decently powerful, running
good card quality can accomplish that goal to
some extent as long as you tread carefully
around potential bottlenecks. If you have a
fundamentally powerful deck concept and you want
to play in a group of more middling power decks,
you can restrict your card choice by
budget or theme or some other factor.
But to this you might ask, what does it mean for
a deck concept to be fundamentally powerful or
fundamentally weak? This takes me back to the core
question of this video—the question of when a deck
should be upgraded with better card quality. I
mentioned Feather as an example of a deck that
generally performs solidly on a low budget, but
which can be difficult and cost-inefficient to
improve from that point. As a point of contrast,
I want to talk about a different popular
commander that, like Feather, tends to convert
a specific card type into resources for a fast
gameplan—Yuriko, the Tiger’s Shadow. Yuriko decks
span a range of power levels and contain a lot
of variety in subthemes and card choices, but all
of them share a fundamental gameplan—play evasive
creatures and/or Ninjas, and utilize these cards
with Yuriko to whittle down your opponents through
a mixture of combat damage and Yuriko triggers,
generating card advantage in the process. Yuriko
notably doesn’t have the same ceiling as
Feather because she’s fundamentally a faster,
more resilient, and just simpler card. Commander
ninjutsu at two mana immediately puts her head
and shoulders above Feather in terms of raw power,
and instead of being fiddly and requiring constant
upkeep or extra steps to reach her full power,
she converts low cost ninjas and evasive creatures
into very fundamental resources of the game—card
advantage, and life loss for opponents—and can do
so with minimal mana investment. Decks can vary in
how many ninjas they run and what sorts of evasive
creatures they play, but these cards are basically
guaranteed to be effective due to the speed,
resilience, and simplicity of Yuriko, and as long
as a deck is above a certain minimum number of
these supporting creatures, these cards combine
with Yuriko to form a very powerful core to
the deck. It’s this strong core for generating
generic resources that makes a deck especially
upgradable—there’s a good amount of diversity
in what a successful Yuriko deck can look like,
and there are lots of piecemeal card quality
upgrades and packages that can be added to
modulate the deck to whatever power level the
Yuriko player wants to be playing at. By contrast,
core of a Feather deck is worse and less flexible
overall, which leaves flickering Dockside
Extortionist as one of the few genuinely strong
things the deck can do in high power casual games.
I think it’s worth clarifying here that there’s
nothing wrong with commanders that are better
suited to mid-power, nor is a commander like
Yuriko or Korvold that inherently pushes a
higher power necessarily more interesting or more
worthwhile. There are also the players who like
the challenge of trying to boost a commander
or theme that isn’t inherently high power up
to that point, and that can be a fun process.
I personally like the challenge of building
powerful decks on a low budget, as it forces
you to put a lot of effort into the cohesion
of the deck since the card quality is going to be
naturally a bit lacking. At the end of the day,
I just want people to know what they’re getting
into when they decide to pour time and money
into a deck. If you have a limit on how much
you want to spend on decks, it’s valuable to
know when you’re dealing with a commander who
will naturally take more money to boost from a
mid-power deck to a high-power deck, and as stated
earlier, this will fundamentally come down to how
powerful a deck’s core resource-generating
and game-winning pieces are. And even if
budget isn’t a concern, it’s worth keeping an
eye on a deck’s weak points and making sure
that they aren’t going to be exacerbated
by playing against more powerful decks.
I feel like there’s a culture among a lot of EDH
players of higher power decks being considered
cooler or more interesting, which leads to this
sort of rat race of chasing generic staples and
applying formulaic rules to every deck to bump
up its power level. And I don’t want to tell
anybody not to improve a deck they want to
improve, but I just want to tell you right
now that if you have a mid-power deck you
really like, you don’t necessarily need to
change it. If you do want a higher power deck,
you can pick out a couple things you like from
an existing deck you enjoy such as a card or a
theme, and then build a new, more powerful home
for it. This also goes for putting pet cards
in decks, but that’s a topic for another day.